how do you figure out which one to do
recycle sell trash when is it worth it
to go through the hassle of selling
versus donating so this is very similar
to Kristina's question yeah I think so
my pithy answer is when getting rid of
old possessions sell whenever it makes
sense if you can't sell in 30 days and
I'm changing that now I'm gonna change
that to seven days no legen change this
in the minimal Maxim's so this is really
my recipe for for letting go so I'll
start over again when getting rid of old
possessions sell whenever it makes sense
if you can't sell in seven days
donate immediately if you can't donate
recycle if you can't recycle trash it
and I just want to talk real quick about
the be one in ten out rule em in a new
essay on our website about it's
something that really helped me early on
because I was so overwhelmed with
letting go but I was also overwhelmed by
well of course I want to bring new
things in am I never allowed to bring
anything new into my life now that I'm
becoming a minimalist well no I and so I
found a way to sort of do both anytime I
wanted to bring something very
intentionally into my life something new
a new t-shirt I had to read let go of
ten items so if it was a new t-shirt it
was like ten pieces of clothing I'm
going to let go a new blender I thought
I'd go of tin kitchen items and so forth
and so on and and what you realized in
that process is like oh the things I'm
bringing them into my life I'm curating
and bringing in only the things I need
but then also it's forcing me before I
can go buy the item to let go of those
10 things so I'll put a link to that in
the show notes as well we're just like
reliving my leg clutter and and getting
rid of my clutter yeah and it's just it
feels so good to get rid of it man like
I suspect when you get to get to good
terms with that with that uh that
economic term son cost it's just freeing
man it's so freeing
alright my short answer is this there's
a it's this Josh there's an official
rule book for minimalism and you're the
author so here's the thing Caroline that
the one in ten out of the twenty twenty
rule thirty thirty rule of ninety ninety
rule the whatever it is these are Josh
and i's rules that we use we have
written our own rule book and we differ
on a couple of rules yeah
it's okay but like Carolyn you get to
write the rules what are your rules what
does your meaningful life look like what
is gonna make sense for your household
you know when I think about the ninety
nine year old for example that is a
great rule it doesn't work all the time
for me because I got things like a
snowboard and stuff that isn't really
necessarily going to fall into that rule
but setting up these boundaries are what
helps us to get through these questions
but but yeah Caroline you get to write
the rulebook
and the nice thing about that is uh is
creating rules that challenge you you
don't want rules that are easy that's
not the whole point of this right you
get to write that rulebook so that you
can challenge yourself that there's a
new essay owner on our website recently
I wrote about my rule of two and and for
me it's like I get overwhelmed with a
lot of health stuff because I've been
radically improving my and my health
over the last two years or so and I want
to do everything every day I want to
make sure I go to the sauna and I want
to do my push-ups and my pull-ups and my
squats and I want to make it to the gym
I was a good therapy yeah physical
therapy and cycling and yoga and and
sauna and but all these things that I
want to do and it becomes overwhelming
and so the rule that I made for myself
was still challenging it's there are
eleven things I like to do every single
week twice a week and and of those
things as long as I do them twice I give
myself permission to feel satisfied and
then if I do them more than twice I feel
like a champion as opposed to changing
the expectation if it was every day and
I only did them six times it'd be like
oh well you failed so set and set some
rules up that that are difficult but
they also don't set you up for failure
you don't want to set up rules that are
impossible for you you don't want the
five five rule if I haven't used in this
the last five days I have to get rid of
it immediately by visas the last five
minutes one of the next five minutes
standing there naked yeah so so create
rules that are empowering that allow you
to move forward in the right direction
allow you to grow but also keep in mind
you want rules there that challenge you
you